VR fails are some of the [__]
funniest videos 100% people destroying
their furniture and [__] getting scared
running scking people dude I saw one
where a guy ran into a wall and just
knocked himself out cold [__] two black
eyes after and
[Music]
[__] we're going to finally jump in
about the console Wars okay console Wars
we're jumping in what is that you don't
know about the console Wars wars gaming
consoles or we're talking about it's
always Xbox versus PlayStation come on
let's the newest one came out what about
N64 shut you're going to stay out of
this one yeah you're going to stay
out you guys aren't inclusive at all man
so PlayStation 5 has outsold Xbox series
X N S 3 to one in 2023 wow I feel like
PS5 is more popular than General oh for
sure it's definitely been more popular
over the years too like I think it was 3
to one though well they actually
Microsoft kind of caught up I thought
Microsoft was doing better this time
around Microsoft in general but not
their Xbox console I felt like PS5 I was
trying to get PS5 for a while so and I
couldn't get one for a while cuz they
were just sold out so I just imagined
that Xbox is just selling more units but
I guess I'm completely [__] wrong in
my you're an idiot too you're talking
about the one that's sold out being like
not as good if it's sold out for if it's
sold out for 6 months that means no
one's buying it for you're like dude all
these Xboxes are available they must be
selling way more
yeah bro it's f econom supply and Dem
have an endless supply so what do you
think's going on as a gamer what do you
think's going on I just think Sony's
just put out better games what like what
like ghost of sushima God of War
bringing back Final Fantasy uh
Spider-Man and Spider-Man 2 the Miles
Morales stuff um Elder ring like just
everything that's going all the tripa
titles yeah yeah everything that's going
to Sony is just like way better and the
new and the the Xbox games I've been
hearing cuz cuz I haven't played them
yet I heard the new Halo's whack I don't
even play Halo I haven't even heard Halo
in the conversation in a long not in a
while right the only time I've ever
heard of Halo recently is like when you
talk about Halo or in in in throwback
conversations never like AK when he
talks about Halo cuz I'm really good at
Halo you talk about things you're good
at you got a guy that's been trying to
get a hold of you and he says he'll beat
you in I told him I'll stunted all over
his dumb ass if you beat him if you beat
him he'll give you a Bitcoin what one
Bitcoin he thinks he's that good he's
trying to dude he doesn't know who the
[__] he's talking to bro I will stunt
all over his [__] ass would you
be willing to wager one Bitcoin no [__]
no I'm never giving anybody my crypto by
the way in my in my in crypto corner I
told I've been trying to give away my
woo for two [__] years straight if
anybody can beat me in fantasy football
nobody can wow don't don't you don't
know who you're talking to sometimes be
careful out
there which halo which Halo is your
we're playing Halo too it's this guy is
going to be crying to his
mama and if his mama's not around
anymore he might have to make her on AI
so we can cry to
her
jeez the only game I have that kind of
confidence for is Connect 4 yeah you
good at Connect Four pretty good
especially if there's a time limit are
you do you play in an unorthodox way
that's no I just if we if we go like I
put in something you have to put in
right after and you can't
[__] I'll
smoke people dude Nikki would [__]
wreck your ass at connect she's a
Connect Four I was also one of those
daycare losers so I played for like 6
hours a day every single day so was she
she was a lash kid my mom didn't pick me
up until like 9:00 p.m. at night you
play Connect for alone no I play with
the [__] with [__] Mary Jane the the
daycare lady better at Connect 4 without
any friends dude that's that's what what
do you mean you playing yourself yeah
yeah you run back all the strategies you
run all combinations yeah after I
destroy Mary Jane the [__] daycare
lady I play myself it's like playing
yourself in chess yep or Battleship you
memorize options I wish I played a more
productive game like chess but I just
got glued to [__] Connect 4 Connect 4
is a solid game bro you could have made
money if you play Jess I know there's no
connect for tournaments although Al
classic JK there's going to be some in
the comments there are connect for
tournament Steve doesn't know what he's
talking about again again again do do
you guys have a console yeah play I
don't anymore switch PS5 switch I have
switch too is switch in the combo at all
in this no n d they're getting I mean
they wreck it but like the teenagers are
too cool to play switch it's like for
kids can I ask a question what's a
switch nint Nintendo switch it's a it's
a Will Smith hit song it's called a
switch because you can play a handheld
but you can also plug it in as a console
we we tagged you out of this one B I
want to be in too yeah the second he
jumps in brings it right back to connect
it's
like I recently played a VR right and
then I'm like it's actually really
[__] fun VR is sick dude but then the
next day I was stretching and I'm like
how the [__] did I get so sore but I
remember bre was your neck no my legs
but we were crouching it's it's like
super interactive but it's so fun that I
think you don't realize how much you're
moving and then so the next day I was
like [__] sword I'm like what the
[__] like this would be a great exercise
thing and then the guy that runs the uh
VR Studio was like yeah there's ladies
that come in here like straight up yoga
outfit like ready to work out they'll
buy a few sessions they'll be [__]
drenched and sweat for like 2 hours and
that's their gym dude but when the
pandemic happened I had a Oculus and
there was this boxing game and it's
pretty [__] sick and all you do is
you're boxing [__] up you're
burning you're doing three minute rounds
it feels like pretty real and you're
like and the guy is coming at you and
you're like you're moving around like
you're you're actually boxing box oh wow
and afterwards I'm just sweating pouring
and I'm like this is [__] sick I
don't need a I don't need a gym dude I
love that lasted like two days that's
such a man thing to do like when Pokemon
go came out all these all these guys
like I don't need to [__] work out
anymore I got Pokemon go I'm doing
12,000 steps a day and [__] I'm a fit
guy now yeah that was absolutely me
getting beat up in Virtual
getting knocked out again in
Virtual but after I played that I was
like dude it it's crazy how you War to a
different planet like in one second and
then and then you're in there so then
that becomes your reality you're just
[__] shooting stuff and I'm like dude
when the graphics get real this is going
to be it's game over over especially
it's interactive like I've once a VR
thing with like a bunch of homies once
and it's like you're playing a shooting
game with like six other dudes we did
that insane wait did you do one where
you free roam or is it like you're in a
you're in like an area but it's like
dude you can't [__] get me dog I'm
over here juking people in VR no I'm not
I lied I made that up yeah I sucked at
it I was really bad I lost no one
[__] no one no one believed it I lost
money at it there's one it's kind of
like um Airsoft where it's like real
life Counterstrike and then you you're
in a room and it's just free running it
looks [__] cool I played one of those
in China actually it literally has a
giant room and you have like a almost
like a harness a vest on yeah no it's
not a harness because it's you're in a
room and then the thing is like
basically built to the dimensions of the
room so like when you see in your VR you
might see just like a bridge so you're
only you can only walk on that because
you're not going to jump over and like
die so you're like you see these people
including yourself you're just like
pretending like you're walking in one
spot and you're only given certain areas
to walk oh [__] you so everybody
everything fits but it does feel crazy
and you're like shooting each other and
stuff like that but it's it's dope it's
just like it's like playing PlayStation
one though everything's like boxy yeah
everything has like slow load times or
like you know what I mean or like what
you're wearing is [__] heavy that's
why you're sweating you know but when it
gets there it's probably going to be
crazy it's going to be like Avatar where
you [__] teleport into a body and
[__] I'm going to be doing battle rolls
in VR dude rolling my shoulder and [__]
breaking your Oculus slaming on the
ground yeah cuz it's very front heavy
and [__] VR fails are some of the
[__] funniest videos people
destroying their Furniture [__] getting
scared running and socking people dude I
saw one where a guy ran into a wall and
just knocked himself out cold [__] two
black eyes afterwards and [__] back to
these console Wars what's up well I mean
I like what you said about it so you you
know PlayStation you think is destroying
them because of games yeah I think
you're right I think well there's more
game selections well Xbox has been
buying up like they bought Bethesda
recently they did like the Elder Scrolls
series series and they did like that
Starfield game that everyone says sucks
are more people just playing PC in
general though like I feel like that
seems to be the more popular route I
mean in general most people play PC like
gamer Gamers but when we're talking
about from a console point of view it's
like you also got to think about like
kids still like main like when you're
talking about like sales and numbers and
stuff it's like how many kids are
jumping on this for what reason because
if you're a PC Gamer you're just there's
no end to the amount of money you're
spending yeah that's true not
everybody's going to have that life
that's true I feel like kids don't even
[__] play video games
that's all they do man and they watch
people play if you want to talk to
someone that's misogynist and racist and
that's going to [__] call you out
like go on Xbox and talk to a 9-year-old
plus a lot of like the hit PlayStation
games they don't come out to PC for for
like a year sometimes like I'll never
play [__] God of War unless unless I
buy a PlayStation 5 basically they
they're really smart about the way they
do it that's that's a big that's a big
factor too is that PlayStation owns so
many of the past titles that have been
hits yeah and they won't go on other
consoles and then the the backwards uh
not backwards compatibility but the on
the PlayStation Store how far back in
time you can go and buy games that you
played when you were a teenager The
Nostalgia is way [__] high it's it's
crazy it is crazy though what a graphic
snob I'm becoming because like I I I
tried to play Metal Gear Solid like a
couple years ago just the OG Metal Gear
Solid and like the graphics are so it
looks like [__] it looks like [__] well
even even some of those old games like
Yakuza series they're they're getting
kiwami uh which is like the the remake
where they make it look as good as today
but it's a game from the [__] early
2000s really so they're like updating
the and you and then you buy that on the
PlayStation Store digitally so it's like
yeah the next game I'm playing on
Playstation is The Last of Us two
remastered yeah the REM oh yeah the
remaster cool it's just like oh cool
they're digital snob yeah you're just
kind of like I don't know if I can play
this and there like remaster you're like
[__] yeah I want to play it if they did
that to the old GTA Series game over
Dude they did it already oh they did
yeah it's modern yeah they did a
remastered Series so guess Joe it's game
over dude all of them Hey Joe then it's
game over then game over so you are you
but but they got really bad reviews oh
really yeah it was a bad Port right
because the company that ported it over
and and remade them wasn't the same
company it's not Rockstar it was
outsourced to a different like company
and they did a bad
job yeah and it's almost like that
proves that maybe some games you don't
really need to do that too and you know
in terms of M remaking old GTA the
modders have taken care of that for PC
like by far dude GTA 6
what do you think [__] I can't wait it's
going to be on we're going to be a gang
I think dude I'm not going to be at JK
news I'm going to be gone I'm going to
be gone yeah Joe's missing hey connect
for two dude I'm I'm I'm such a PC guy
dude when we when GTA 6 comes out though
we should play We Should stream we
should like we should be a crew we'll be
a crew I bet you the footage if we were
playing games together Connect 4 would
be more viral it's probably not going to
have an online multiplayer until like 2
years years after the release though no
it'll be at the same time they made so
much money but they didn't do that with
GTA V well maybe they learn from but
they made all their money on GTA on uh
on the online thing compared to the game
sales yeah they did later they did but
they didn't they didn't release it for
you don't think they'll release online
at the same time I don't think so oh
you're breaking my heart I I think they
should have but they never do oh [__]
you're right that's a lot is it I think
they should but that's true cuz then
they they won't be able to maximize
their their earnings that way they have
to release that first and then after
people done with the story mode you know
yeah I think I think they there's a
reason for that but I don't I wish they
would do it right away they better do it
right away dude this time I think also
PlayStation has a different genre of
like if you play classic japanese RPGs
those are mostly on Sony oh like Final
Fantasy you're just talking about
yourself yeah like so when I play it's
on Playstation it is yeah but that's a
whole like community of people that will
only buy PlayStation because that's the
only place you can get them well and I I
don't think even think Xbox sells in
Japan not not well it sells but not well
yeah I mean fpss don't even sell in
Japan really people don't generally like
to play Shooters as much as they do like
cutesy games makes
sense arcades are still have you guys
ever been a
[Music]
console